عائد النصر يوم للتاريخ في روسيا
وجمهوريات الاتحاد السوفيتي يصادف التاسعه
من مايو من كل عام في هذا العام يتم
الاحتفال بالذكرى الثامنه والسبعين
للانتصار على النازيه في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كالعاده في يوم التاسع من مايو
تشهد الساحه الحمراء في موسكو احتفالا
عسكريا ضخما بمناسبه هذه المناسبات تتشارك
معها في الاحتفال بنفس اليوم اوكرانيا لكن
الاختلاف في هذا العام كان سيد الموقف
فوكرانيا اختارت الاحتفال في عيد النصر
يوم الثامن من مايو اما روسيا التي كانت
تراهن في حربها باوكرانيا على النصر
فاحتفلت فيه من دون نصر كان رفع المقترح
للبرلمان لتغيير تاريخ عيد النصر الى
الثامن من مايو وقال انه لا يمكن نسيان
المساهمه الكبيره التي قدمتها اوكرانيا في
الانتصار على النازيه لذاك وقال انه من
الان فصاعدا سيكون التاسع من مايوه هو يوم
اوروبا في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي اوكرانيا
وان الاحتفال هذا العام بيوم اوروبا في
كييف المكان المثالي للاحتفال بيوم اوروبا
اما الاختلاف في روسيا فكان فقط في تجديد
الاجراءات الامنيه في مكان الاحتفال الذي
انطلق صباح اليوم بحضور الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين في عرض عسكري ضم عشرات الالاف من
الجنود الروسي شاركت فيه المدرعات
والدبابات الروسيه ومنظومه يارس والعابره
للقارات واسكندر واس 400 لم يغب عن المشهد
كذلك سلاح الجو الروسي لطائرات سخوي
[موسيقى]